[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by maulin ackerman
and lorenza izzo who starring the aviary
which is out in theaters and on demand
friday how you guys doing today
great for you
yeah i'm really i'm doing good i'm
excited to talk to you guys so
mullin which i thought was really
interesting about this is that you're
also an executive producer on this so
when you're acting in as a lead as well
is that challenging do you have like
both hats on at once or do you have to
like kind of separate that
um no not really i mean this was such a
wonderful shoot there weren't many uh
issues that needed to be discussed it's
more it was more the
putting it together in the beginning you
know and getting everyone
on board and figuring out how we wanted
to make this it's just that thing of
um
if i'm i'm going to play a lead in
something it's nice to have some
creative say uh in in how this is going
to go down because it falls on our
shoulders on myself and lorenzo and so
um it just
gets you to
to get behind it even more so um
but it was really just it was it was a
cinch we had the best people involved a
great crew and chris and jennifer um
writer directors were just absolutely a
pleasure to work with
so um it wasn't too much it was more
just focusing on on
the the the actual script and what was
that hand lorenzo and i playing these
crazy roles
yeah no that's a great answer and it's
exciting to hear that it was like a good
set good crew and i think it's cool too
that you're producing so much stuff now
which i'm excited to see what you bring
out next now
lorenza having starred in a couple of
horrors and thrillers already now and
now doing this
are you a fan of the genre yourself like
watching the genre are you like a horror
person or you does that just happen to
be what you're acting i'm actually
consciously taking a break from horror
like for a few years i i didn't do
anything even remotely scary because i i
i had done it a lot and i just wanted to
i'm of a mind of wanting to do
everything all kinds of different
artists and just diving into different
media but
when i read the script i was like this
is amazing
human mind horror which i find the
scariest like give me that over anything
i am not a fan of watching horror i get
scared so easily i watch movies but like
it's just i don't even do it you have to
like really like trick me like my
friends will trick me into watching them
that's the only way i'll watch a scary
movie or a horror movie so
this one to me was just it was just so
well written chris and jen did a
phenomenal job writing it and and and
for me you know it was in the middle of
covet i'm a huge fan of mullins and i
was like this is something i need to do
this type of scary is a really really
like uh
incredibly psychologically scary scary
so
it was it was kind of a no-brainer
yeah no and you absolutely crush it here
and it's exciting to see you like really
go to intense levels in this film so i'm
excited for people to see that and now
malin i have to bring up to i am the
biggest fan of this movie wanderlust i
remember going to a theater didn't know
what i was even seeing and i was blown
away especially by a performance in that
so i want to know
with your range and all these different
roles you do is comedy acting the most
challenging as a lot of actors say or
would you disagree with that
for me personally comedy acting is
where i feel the most comfortable
um i i just have grown up in a in a life
full of sarcasm and i i feel great
around all of it um i personally think
things like this film are more
challenging
uh there's just so much more you know
with comedy it's all about timing and so
you really have to have
great directors and great people to work
with because if the timing's off then
the whole thing is off and you can just
it's a bust but i mean wunderless you
were mentioning some of the best
comedian with paul rudd i mean it was
i could barely keep a straight face it
was that was the biggest challenge is
this
movie it is
oh yeah yeah and um you're being humble
because timing is also foreign you have
to naturally have it like or you have to
really work on it and you're like just
like naturally incredibly
good at that
yes totally and
lorenza having worked with a legend like
quentin tarantino recently is there
anything you learn from being on that
set that you bring with you now to your
current projects
oh my god
a lot but you know what more than
anything enjoyment quentin enjoys what
he does so much there's such a special
energy in his sets of like
can you believe that this is what we're
doing he does a thing where it's like
4am or like really tired everyone's
exhausted and like we're supposed to
wrap we're already over time and like
everyone goes quiet and he'll go and why
do we do this and then the whole crew
and the cast will go because we love
making movies
just like remember the first time here
that literally everybody on set like
that was a huge thought it was like over
200 people we were shooting the the
ending scene and
we did that a couple of times and
there's just such a natural authentic
joy for what that man does that it just
translated it's like we were all doing
it was like brad pitt and me and i'm
like we love making movies what is it
that's something i'll never forget that
i take
i love that answer everybody you know
just watch these two absolutely kill it
in the aviary which is in theaters on
demand this friday marlon and lorenzo
thank you so much for joining me we'll
talk to you in the future one day thank
you i hope so